[Music]
on this tuesday night putting a global
price on pollution
the prime minister's pitch to the world
it's an extremely powerful tool plus the
country's refusing to join the pledge to
slash methane emissions
the blackhawks sex abuse scandal the
former assistant gm cleared but still
repentant kyle was failed by a system
that should have helped him
the taliban's rebrand they are not
trustable why afghans aren't buying this
softer side of a terrorist organization
to preserve and protect the young
climate activists on a mission to create
a better world
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight robin gill good
evening and thank you for joining us we
begin tonight in glasgow with the push
to protect the planet prime minister
justin trudeau urged his global
counterparts at the u.n climate
conference to put a minimum price on
carbon emissions he's also backing a u.s
and eu-led partnership to cut methane
emissions by 2030. methane accounts for
25 of the world's greenhouse gas
emissions it's more potent than co2 and
it traps far more heat the global pledge
aims to reduce methane emissions by 30
percent compared with 2020 levels canada
has joined nearly a hundred countries in
signing up for the initiative but three
of the world's top pollution powerhouses
china russia and india did not commit to
the agreement our michael couture joins
us from glasgow and might guide us
through what canada is committing to
well robin canada supports the global
methane pledge and last month announced
the government will develop a plan to
reduce methane across the economy
including methane emissions from the oil
and gas sector by at least 75 percent in
the next nine years and today trudeau
was adding to the canadian ambition
theme urging world leaders to put a
global price on pollution the carbon
pricing is one of the most powerful ways
of reducing emissions once a
controversial statement today is
supported by some of the world's
economic leaders joined by the head of
the imf wto and european commission
prime minister justin trudeau made his
pitch for a global price on pollution we
should be ambitious and say as of right
here today that we want to triple that
60 percent of global emissions should be
covered by a price on pollution in 2030.
trudeau says pricing pollution is seen
as the best way to keep global
temperatures from rising more than 1.5
degrees celsius the biggest issue is
equity while action is needed poorer
countries can't afford to be as bold as
others for poor countries
it is lower
for middle-income countries somewhat
higher for rich economies
of course they need to strive to pay
more after an election where canadian
parties of all stripes agreed to put a
price on pollution trudeau believes
canada can lead on this issue in fact
our carbon price will rise to 170
dollars per ton by the year 2030 but
even big polluters like the u.s have yet
to price carbon federally it's why
environmental activists say canada needs
to go much further to say to the world
that we're going to limit global warming
to 1.5 well canada is not there and so
we do need those kind of measures that
are going to complement what we've
already done so far after serving as the
head of the bank of canada and the bank
of england mark carney the current u.n
special envoy for climate action and
finance acknowledges policy changes are
needed to affect more change yes it's
complicated if any major jurisdiction
doesn't have a price on carbon
however i'd note the u.s intentions to
have a clean grid by 2035. to that end
trudeau gave a concrete example of how
change on a global scale is possible a
few years ago
nobody would have even imagined that we
could set a global minimum corporate tax
and suddenly we have trudeau believes
the same is true for pricing carbon and
he urged the world it's better to be a
leader than be dragged behind
robin michael couture in glasgow
scotland thanks mike
let's end
this great global chainsaw massacre
110 nations including canada are also
vowing to end deforestation by 2030 and
reverse the loss of forests the
countries signing on represent 85
percent of the planet's forested land
the agreement comes with a pledge of
over 19 billion dollars in public and
private funds to help developing nations
restore land that has already been
degraded protecting the world's force is
key to reducing greenhouse gases and
keeping global temperatures from rising
above 1.5 degrees celsius
forests they store around 30 of the
terrestrial carbon on the planet
deforestation and conversion and
agriculture you know contributes around
about 30 percent of of all current
climate emissions so it's really really
critical
a previous deal signed in 2014 failed to
stop deforestation
now to some breaking news out of the u.s
advisors to the u.s centers for disease
control and prevention have unanimously
recommended the pfizer coveted vaccine
for kids aged 5 to 11. there is now just
one step left in the u.s approval
process the director of the cdc must
sign off on a recommendation there are
reports that could happen as early as
tonight the first shots could be
administered to american kids as early
as tomorrow morning
pfizer has submitted an application to
health canada for approval of its kids
vaccine in this country that application
is still under review the canadian
government is expanding the list of
airports accepting international flights
the government says starting november
30th international flights will be
allowed to land at eight more airports
across the country from saint john's to
victoria bc they'll join the 10 airports
already authorized to accept flights
from abroad
there's a new development tonight in the
chicago blackhawks sexual abuse scandal
winnipeg jets general manager kevin
shoveldayoff has spoken to the media for
the first time about his connection to
the allegations shovel dayoff was
assistant general manager of the
blackhawks in 2010 when then player kyle
beach was allegedly assaulted by a video
coach an independent investigation found
that beach told management about the
allegations and nothing was done shovel
dayoff was at the management meeting
where the allegations were discussed but
the nhl decided not to discipline him
they say he was not responsible for how
the allegations were handled
today chevrolet said he was unaware at
the time of the extent of the
allegations he apologized to beech for
the system failing him
what kyle went through is
unacceptable and intolerable
no one
should ever have to go through what he
went through
kyle was failed by a system that should
have helped him
but did not
i am sorry that i cannot change what
took place
or how the process was handled back then
but i can
learn from this
and make sure that this never happens
again
there will be no jail time for a
teenager found guilty of sexual assault
at toronto's saint michael's college the
judge sentenced the teen to two years
probation for his role in the 2018
assault of another student at the all
boys school
in june he was found guilty of the gang
attack which involved assaulting the
victim with a broom all five students
who pleaded guilty to the same incident
will not face jail time
there was a surprise move today by
ontario premier doug ford three years
after scrapping plans to hike the
minimum wage to fifteen dollars he is
now doing exactly that ford says on
january first minimum wage will go from
14.35 an hour to 15 dollars an hour he
says an estimated 760 thousand workers
will benefit
for many ontarians
wages having kept up with the increasing
cost of living
making it harder than ever to make ends
meet
i've always said workers deserve to have
more money in their pockets
because they earned it
in 2018 after he won the provincial
election ford canceled legislation that
would have increased minimum wage to 15
today the official opposition ndp leader
criticized ford saying 15
doesn't cut it that workers need at
least 17 dollars to cover the cost of
living
now to the u.s where one year after joe
biden's victory voting is once again
underway in state and local races biden
and former president donald trump are
not on the ballot but they're both
central figures in states like virginia
where the governor's race is now too
close to call
jackson proskow is in fairfax virginia
tonight with why this race is crucial to
the white house
hey are you here to be ready to vote
virginia elections are normally safe
territory for democrats with the recent
last four years of donald trump
i didn't even bother looking at what the
candidates were i decided i was boarding
democrats straight down to the bottom
line this time around the governor's
race has turned into a nail biter wake
up virginia here we come let's bring
this baby home
democrat terry mcauliffe and republican
glenn younkin are tied in the polls with
the election swayed by joe biden's
growing unpopularity and the long shadow
of former president donald trump i think
because they're not pushing a democratic
policy they're pushing the
socialist policy i don't think people
are
i don't think that's why people live in
america in recent weeks virginia
democrats have seen their support
evaporate as biden's agenda stalls
america is watching this race
republicans have seized the opportunity
to campaign against vaccine mandates and
more progressive curriculums in schools
while donald trump weighs in from the
sidelines the republicans have lost in
virginia for 10 straight years they're
desperate to win one and now conditions
permit them to win
so their enthusiasm level is through the
roof democrats are blase about it
the fact that the virginia race is even
close could spell trouble for democrats
nationwide a sign voters have turned
away one year before midterm elections
i'd like to see everybody come together
and be able to work together but that's
not where we're at right now yet
virginia also offers clues about the
limits of donald trump's future appeal
should he try a comeback in 2024
trump wasn't invited to campaign
alongside yunkin but did endorse him he
remains both an asset and a liability to
the party even though he's not on the
ballot trump still looms large here in
fact his lies about a stolen election in
2020 have forced a change in the way
results will be reported out tonight
with mail-in and absentee results
delivered first and in-person votes
released later
robin jackson brosco in fairfax virginia
the taliban's diplomatic dance to woo
the world but is this charm offensive
enough to get the help this country
needs that's coming up
at least 20 people are dead after an
attack on afghanistan's biggest military
hospital two explosions hit the site in
central kabul this is the latest in a
string of killings since the taliban
takeover no one has claimed
responsibility
the united nations warns afghanistan is
on the brink of becoming the world's
worst humanitarian crisis the country is
desperate for foreign aid and in an
effort to win over the international
community the taliban is trying to show
a friendlier face but few are buying
that the terror group has changed its
ways jeff semple reports from kabul and
a warning some of the images in this
story may be disturbing
the canadian embassy in afghanistan sits
abandoned and it looks like staff left
in a hurry the canadian government says
it has no plans to return here to a
country controlled by what it calls a
terrorist organization
this is not an accurate definition of us
if they are saying we are a terrorist
regime canada should behave more
responsibly said the taliban's official
spokesperson
the time for war is over it's a new
season we want good diplomatic relations
with canada and all countries after 20
years of fighting the taliban is
launching a new charm offensive posing
for photographs and inviting foreign
journalists to see a country it says is
safer and free of corruption
[Music]
people were only afraid of the taliban
because of western media propaganda says
this deputy commander we are fighting
for the country afghans are not afraid
anymore
the taliban allowed us to monitor one of
their patrols here on the streets of
kabul as the extremist group tries to
project a friendlier face to the outside
world at the same time it's also seeking
international recognition and
desperately needed foreign aid
the un warns afghanistan is on the brink
of becoming the world's worst
humanitarian crisis
the situation's so desperate this family
is selling one of their own children to
buy food for the others
i'm required to say i'm happy with the
taliban this man scoffs the price of
flour has doubled everyone is unemployed
we need help
the taliban is hoping these scenes will
persuade the international community to
open their purse strings but canada and
its allies fear empowering the taliban
to return to the medieval methods of its
first rule when women were prisoners in
their own homes and kabul's soccer
stadium hosted public executions
today criminal cases are heard by this
taliban primary court
this man says a police officer from the
former government killed his brother
the punishment for murder is death the
taliban commander says asked what
evidence was provided or whether the
accused will be publicly executed he
declines to answer we ask this commander
if the taliban has truly changed
a muslim will never change his ideology
he will follow the quran and sharia law
but the taliban is more skilled in
politics than it was 20 years ago he
says
some afghans say that politically savvy
taliban is conducting its operations not
under a stadium spotlight but in the
shadows
we're hiding this man's identity because
he used to work security at the canadian
forces base in kandahar he says his
father and brother were killed by the
taliban while another brother was
recently found with photos of the
canadian military on his phone he says
the taliban took him away and beat him
nearly to death other videos shared with
global news appear to show taliban going
door to door conducting torture and
executions inside homes or in outlying
areas far from the capitol we cannot
trust them
because they are not trustable this
former canadian interpreter believes
that once the taliban achieves some
international concessions it will show
its true face whatever they say it's
just they also learned politics somehow
but
everybody knows the truth they fought
for 20 years so do you really think it's
going to be over like
never happen we are their enemies they
will take their revenge in 20 years he
says afghanistan has changed but the
taliban has not
jeff semple global news kabul
still ahead why it's taking longer and
costing more to build new houses
the pandemic has sparked a frenzy in
home buying if it's a new bill don't
expect to move in quickly the canadian
home builders association says the
average home construction project is
facing a delay of seven weeks and it'll
cost you more as ann gaviola explains it
all comes down to supply
maya and val's move into their first
house was delayed several times during
the pandemic they were supposed to take
possession in may but only got the keys
half a year later after the birth of
their first child
we were definitely
going through through some stress
lots of emotions at play but i guess we
were kind of able to get through it they
were lucky to be able to stay with
parents while they waited for their home
to be ready if you're going to be moving
make sure to
do it before
having the birth of a child i'll say
that kind of complicates things a little
bit the canadian homebuilders
association says this type of lengthy
hold up is becoming common from coast to
coast to coast on average
in canada we're seeing delays on
closings of about seven weeks about a
quarter of our members are experiencing
delays of more than nine weeks supply
chain snarls hit construction throughout
the home building process resulting in
lengthy delays now once people get into
their home there are long waits for
appliances plumbing materials windows
bathtubs even garage doors to slow
things down even more there's a shortage
of skilled laborers to tackle the
massive backlog the cost of raw goods is
a factor too the price of lumber hit
record highs earlier this year the
housing frenzy created an historic
lumber shortage tim hadl's home framing
business is busier than ever but he
can't hire enough people to meet all the
demand
it's a great problem to have but it is
frustrating he's been in the business
for two decades and says he's never seen
supply chain issues like he's seeing now
we've had to delay some projects just
because of
shortages of materials my crystal ball
says about another year before we are
actually back to a normal these extra
complications come as demand for houses
and more space has spiked because of the
pandemic putting additional strain on
limited supply and further stoking an
already hot housing market ann gaviola
global news toronto
up next nothing about us without us
youth calls for climate action
outer space just got spicier nasa
scientists have picked the first peppers
grown on the international space station
their hatch chili's a type found in new
mexico to celebrate the harvest one
astronaut used the peppers to make what
she calls her best space tacos yet
back on earth world leaders have a lot
on their plates during cop 26 in glasgow
the u.n climate summit is a chance for
leaders to push each other to move
faster on climate action crystal
commansing reports on the young people
fighting for a seat at negotiating
tables
young people are raising up their voices
and advocating for a safe clean livable
planet but being taken seriously is
another story we need to stop thinking
about old debates because we need a new
vision for a new future so you need to
invest your time money and effort in us
to shape our future
more than one million young people have
added their voices by signing a petition
online by the global citizen movement
advance unicef is also calling on
leaders to include young voices in the
decision-making process you know there
are young people who are doing very
brave direct action to show the world
and show their leaders why action needs
to be taken on climate change there are
young people who know every sub-clause
of the paris agreement who are in these
negotiation spaces who are advocating on
behalf of young people this is shakti
ram kumar's second cop summit a
sustainability undergrad at ubc she's a
leader with student energy an initiative
aimed at speeding up the transition to
renewables and her passion is shared
according to a survey of g20 nations
canadians have the strongest feelings
that were already in a climate emergency
both among adults and under eight teams
in canada it's it's really it's really
inspiring you are seeing young people
really say
we want climate action and we are not
going to stand by until we until we
really see it we've contributed
disproportionately to the climate crisis
we're one of the handful of wealthy
nations who have kind of taken more than
our fair share of the earth's resources
more than our fair share of the
emissions in the atmosphere and that
means now we can take accountability and
show some leadership a youth-led report
will be released thursday focusing on
the energy transition and where they
most feel investments should be made
young people from 120 countries
including canada help to craft it the
hope is that if young people are armed
with hard data it will add credibility
to their ideas
and their solutions
crystal gomencing global news glasgow
and that is global national for this
tuesday night i'm robin gill tonight
your canada is saint ulrich quebec we
would love to see your favorite parts of
our country so please keep sending your
photos to viewers at globalnational.com
thank you for watching donna friesen
we'll be back at the anchor desk
tomorrow and i'll see you friday have a
great night
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]